[Applause]
wow like 99
of the celebrities that come on the show
are tiny tiny people i'm gigantic yeah
yeah you as well thank you
let's make it out good
um yeah i've been the site since i was
like 12 years old that's horrible
time really mine happened late i i was
one of the i was a small
kid and then when i was about like
literally like 22 suddenly
no no no i was near a radioactive site
and i grew to 6'4 what
12 12 is way too early no 6'4 110 pounds
oh my god no idea how to use my body
whatsoever right just probably leaning
crazily from side to side
and i was i was the only jewish kid in
all christian school and so the kids
they didn't like me that much anyway
and they would uh stand around me in a
circle and they would jump on my back
and yell ride the oath ride the oath
oh my god this sounds like something out
of like a dickensian novel it was
ridiculous it was horrible
this is terrible yeah every class photo
i'm just cut off here at the head
you're cut off and you have 11 kids on
your back yeah exactly
exactly when did you get those kids off
like just a few years ago yeah just
shake them off
so so how did so then eventually uh what
happens is you fill out or i know i will
one day but but you filled out
i'm getting there yeah i'm still the the
height is still awkward like i write a
vespa to work every day
what yeah no you live in los angeles i
do i don't i don't think you you can
ride a vesper around l.a it's kind of
dangerous
it's not only is it dangerous but i'm
also like eight inches too tall to be
riding a vest but
see your knees you're like up here
that's ridiculous and so
i look like big bird basically right and
uh at stoplights
to make my legs a little more
comfortable i stand up and just hold the
bike but it came in handy the other day
because i got rear-ended
boom and i'm stopped at a stoplight but
luckily the vespa just shot out from
under me
and i was like
[Applause]
i just started laughing hysterically i
look like a madman wow
you could have been killed but we all
got to laugh that's the important thing
absolutely um now uh
you're you're having a lot of success uh
with this show yeah no this is uh people
really like the like the program
but you've also uh you've been in movies
you've been on freaks and geeks yeah
you've been around for a while
what is the thing where you that first
got you recognized like you were
someplace and you got recognized for the
first time the first time i got
recognized was here in new york uh i was
living here with
with a girl who was much older than i
was and i was 18. yeah you know what i'm
saying
yeah that's right that's how i do it
yeah
and i used to say that too it was my mom
with a girl much older than me yeah
[Music]
it's embarrassing i can imagine that i
can imagine
so anyway so you're where where are you
and uh well the first movie i did
unfortunately the last scene is me uh is
me masturbating in a confessional
right and it is in fairness how most
movies end
that's hollywood yeah i wasn't
particularly proud of that but
my girlfriend wanted to go to a bar but
i was too young to go to the bar so
she's like don't worry you're so tall no
one will care they won't know right so
we snuck into the bar and i'm terrified
of getting thrown out of this place
and all of a sudden the bartender looks
at me and he says hey you
i'm like oh man i'm about to get thrown
out he says you're the dude who touches
himself
and no one else in the barn knows that
it's from a movie no they think i'm like
the guy in the background he touches
himself yeah
i've seen sketches of you what the [ __ ]
it was horrible conan now um
how i met your mother uh there's a lot
of good writing there's a lot of
in this show about relationships and and
how people try and meet other people
have you picked up anything just by
doing this show have you picked up any
ideas
on how you might meet uh you know a
potential uh girlfriend
sure well there's one episode my
character's only been with one woman his
whole life
and i'm finally single and and the boys
try to teach me how to meet women
and so they show this kind of male
coquettish look where you put your hands
in your pockets
kind of hunch over and tilt tilt your
head to the side just give it a little
give a little smile try it what's this
it looks like this meat giant
so it's just you put your hands in your
pocket and you kind of stand like this
yeah it takes some of the hideout put
your head down yeah
that's it you got it you know the
problem is with that
this is okay you know what the problem
is there's a voice that goes with that
stance and it's on something like this
hi guys how you doing
yeah yeah i don't know about that look
that looks uh
it usually works but i'm often wearing a
how i met your mother hat
which please talk to me yeah exactly